it was a bit easier to make the Forbes
400 list of America's richest people
this year with the minimum net worth
dropping by 200 million dollars to 2.7
billion dollars
still amid surging inflation and
recoiling markets 41 members of the 2021
Forbes 400 dropped off the 2022 list in
all half of the 44 people who made the
list for the first time in 2021 ended up
falling off in 2022 among them Robin
Hood Market's co-founder beiju bot now
worth just over 700 million dollars and
two co-founders of photo bookmarking
site Pinterest Ben Silverman and Paul
skiara more than half of this year's
drop-offs have fortunes rooted in
technology and finance sectors that
contributed nearly two-thirds of last
year's newcomers 15 Tech billionaires
dropped from the ranks including venture
capitalist Jim Breyer seven financiers
from the 2021 Forbes 400 failed to make
this year's cut including cryptocurrency
exchange coinbase's co-founder Fred
ursum and the real estate and Health
Care sector rounded out the top three
hardest hit with five drop-offs a piece
including founder and chairman of to
neck China holding Sun ho bin a U.S
citizen and one of many deadladen
developers in the People's Republic of
China two from the automotive industry
were drop-offs they are also two of the
biggest losers on a percentage basis
compared to a year ago online used car
seller carvana co-founder and CEO Ernest
Garcia III was worth a whopping 9.3
billion dollars on the 2021 list and is
now worth far less than one billion
dollars the fortune of RJ scaringe
founder and CEO of electric truck
startup rivien Automotive plummeted
after the company went public in late
2021
two other notable drop-offs Cameron and
Tyler Winklevoss the value of their
estimated 70 000 Bitcoin funded in part
by 65 million dollars they received from
Facebook in the settlement over the
origins of the company plunged 60 or
nearly 2 billion dollars over 12 months
in addition Forbes estimates that the
Winklevoss twins cryptocurrency exchange
Gemini is worth roughly half as much as
it was in November of 2021 when it
raised 400 million dollars at a 7.1
billion dollar valuation because trading
volumes have plummeted
foreign